the years-long effort to recall
california governor gavin newsom new
cellini patrick bateman has
failed
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff reportedly promised to side with
china over the united states in the
event of war between the two nations and
the funniest man in the world who also
happened to be one of the wisest people
in public life has died totally
unexpectedly
tough couple days even still all hope is
not lost i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from armando rivas
who says the only thing joe biden united
was americans hating him
that's true i do think i actually think
that's true of basically all presidents
and kings and dictators and
any sort of political leader
in a way their function is to unite
people against them that's usually the
effect but the difference between biden
and some of his predecessors is that he
actually deserves it
because look you've seen what's going on
in afghanistan you've seen what's going
on in immigration you've seen what's
going on especially in the economy
notably inflation and when inflation is
running crazy i would strongly recommend
you go check out acre gold i know the
dilemma you want to invest in physical
gold but you're not old rich uncle penny
bags and so you feel that you cannot
come out of pocket and start buying
physical gold well what if i told you
you can start investing in physical gold
for as little as 30 a month you lie
michael i don't i don't lie i don't like
calm down okay
you can do that with acre acre allows
you to invest in their gold bars
subscribe to their gold bars and then
when your gold stash reaches the price
of their gold bars they will discreetly
ship acre gold to your door they've also
got a new 100 a month subscription to a
5 gram gold bar if you want to up the
ante i have really enjoyed investing in
physical precious metals
i think it's a good investment to make
especially in kind of crazy
economic times such as the ones we're
living in i've enjoyed investing in acre
gold right now go to
getacregold.com start investing in
physical gold today make sure you go to
this url because acres giving away a
gold bar to qualify for the giveaway
tweeter post why you should be the
recipient mention at get underscore acre
that's getacreglol.com
thank you aker gold for supporting the
show
the recall effort against gavin newsom
appears to have failed i don't think
they've officially called the race yet
because we've totally upended our
election system so now the counting goes
on for days and days and weeks and weeks
and they've got to find new batches of
mail-in ballots and it's all
really really suspect but from the early
numbers it appears that the recall
failed in a landslide so the insurgent
campaign by larry elder who did
better than i think just about any
republican candidate could have done in
california and he got a lot of support
and was was polling very well in the
surveys before
election i was going to say election day
but it's really now election month or so
he really put up a good campaign and yet
gavin newsom appears to have won
first question i've got for you
do you trust the results
i
tweeted this out i said do you trust the
results overwhelmingly people said no
that's a different question then did
gavin newsom actually win or did he
actually get more votes
to not be recalled than the recall vote
got
there are different questions you can
you can think
that
even fair and square the recall failed
and also think that it wasn't
fair
and also think that it wasn't above
board and also think there was a lot of
fraud
when i asked the question
do you think the election was fair do
you think it's legit
i'm actually not even asking a question
about gavin newsom or larry elder or joe
biden or donald trump or anybody like
that i'm asking a question about
our
form of government
increasingly in recent years on both
sides of the political aisle people do
not trust the integrity of our elections
how how long did we hear about russia
and the collusion and trump stole it in
2016 and then in 2020 they upended the
entire election system took away basic
safeguards for election integrity and
those measures remained in place during
this california recall widespread
mail-in ballots sent out to people
sometimes people received multiple
ballots sometimes people
dead people received ballots sometimes
the ballots that people got had holes in
them where you could see whether or not
they voted for the recall
you had ballot harvesting in california
you had people we played it on the show
local news showing up
and and they show up to the ballot in
the morning and the the election workers
say oh you've already voted and the
people say i haven't already voted and
they say well our records show that you
have so it's it's clear
that i'm not just talking about
individual acts of fraud i'm saying the
whole system does not have integrity and
there are always questions about votes
but especially since the ruling class
used the coronavirus as an excuse to
take away all of our election integrity
measures people i don't care what side
of the aisle you are on but but
especially conservatives
it's it's a widespread problem but it's
you know in particular among
conservatives because we're outside of
the ruling class they just don't have
faith
in
the system and gavin newsom is really
upset about that he says if you have any
questions about how elections are
conducted you ought to be ashamed of
yourself
election fraud stuff is a crock
it's shameful and it's shameful and i
say that i mean that as an american i'm
i'm ashamed i'm disgusted by it stop
grow up people these people literally
are vandalizing
our democracy and trust in our
institutions i care too much about this
nation i care too much about this
country we're debating democracy in
america right now
this big lie this not i mean this
insurrection what the hell is wrong with
these folks
grow up
accept the results there's absolutely
none it's
embarrassing to even respond to that
because it's fantasy they're making
stuff up and it's hurting our country
forget this election guys like me come
and go we are a dime a dozen politicians
quite literally a dime a dozen
it's about our institutions about this
nation it's about trust and confidence
it's about who we are it's about
citizens feeling empowered and that
their voice matters
it's a hell of a thing
it's a hell of a thing do you like huey
lewis in the news you know i think their
crowning achievement is hip to be
squared which is not just no i don't i
can't i can't look at that guy without
seeing american psycho and he is a
psycho because he's gaslighting all of
us
he's saying
if you you're attacking our democracy if
you if you criticize us for removing all
of the election integrity measures that
defend our democracy i mean look this
guy is a crook machine politician he's
tied into the ruling families of
california i don't think the election
was conducted fairly i think probably
the
recall wouldn't have worked even if the
election were conducted fairly okay i'm
not i'm not saying that that uh
actually a a huge avalanche of voters
voted to throw out gavin newsom and
there was a massive you know 70 percent
california support for larry elder and
the ruling class held it in i'm not
saying that i think probably the recall
would have failed anyway just how the
voter registration works in california
but here's what i do know the election
was not conducted fairly when you have
widespread mail-ins it's not fair when
you have holes in your ballot envelopes
it's not fair when you have motor voter
laws and ballot harvesting it's not fair
when you have people showing up to vote
and they're told they already voted it's
not fair okay this guy is a crook his
political party is cheating and and the
ruling class is extremely corrupt and
people are absolutely right not to have
faith in those institutions or those
elections it's not the fault of the
people it's your fault gavin newsom and
it's your fault nancy pelosi and it's
your fault crooked ruling class
and and what's so offensive on top of it
is not just that you're destroying our
constitutional order it's that you're
lying to us about it and and you're
gaslighting us while you do it that's
the pro that is what is shameful i think
that is what is shameful but i i
have said from the beginning the idea
that the recall effort would work even
if it were a totally fair election was
was slim is there did larry elder do
better than we all thought he would or
then then the ruling class and the
democrats thought he would yes he did
but but the the problems in california
are structural and the problems in
california are also just just numbers
games the number of democrats vastly
vastly
outnumbers the number of republicans
beyond california
the the the
ruling class
is so
hollowing out our constitutional order
that you now have the nation's top
general
according to a new report from bob
woodward you have the nation's top
general
colluding with our our country's number
one geopolitical rival our number one
enemy in the event that we go to war
so according to
the washington post take it with a grain
of salt according to bob woodward take
him with a grain of salt
general milly
in a pair of secret phone calls chairman
of the joint chiefs of staff
called his counterpart general lee joe
chang of the people's liberation army
and said that the united states would
not strike china even if president trump
gave the order the first call took place
the first goal that we know about took
place on october 30th so this is before
the presidential election the second
call took place on january 8th this is
after the presidential election after
the
the insurrection
the greatest coup d'etat in american
history
these two phone calls involved millie
saying quote
general lee i want to assure you that
the american government is stable and
everything is going to be okay we are
not going to attack or conduct any
kinetic operations against you
in the second call
he said we're 100 steady everything's
fine democracy can be sloppy sometimes
the message being don't worry don't
worry even if the president gives the
order we're not going to go to war with
china
i have tried to be as
fair about these issues as i possibly
can and i say well you know
the
politics is messy so as general milley
says politics is messy sometimes
whenever you hear conservatives calling
to use the logan act or some obscure
provision of the law to accuse people of
treason and try people for
calling foreign dignitaries or something
i always tamp that down i say that's
actually not how it works
this law really hasn't been used against
people
in this case i i think this man should
should probably be investigated and
tried for a crime
it seems that what he's doing is
tantamount to treason
he's calling our number one enemy and
saying don't worry we're not going to
attack you he further said that if
donald trump does give the order he'll
call and give a warning to the chinese
that is
if not treason outright it's certainly
conspiracy to commit treason
and it is not enough that this obviously
he should resign that goes or be fired
that goes without saying but i think
this goes further
we all joke you know lock her up or lock
him up or this or that i generally don't
think we should jail our our
presidential candidates
this guy should face very serious
consequences he is compromising civilian
control of the military
this is a key provision of our
constitutional republic so many other
aspects of our constitutional order have
been destroyed by our sick psychotic
ruling class and psychopathic i should
say ruling class
this is probably the most dangerous of
all throw the book at him marco rubio is
calling for millie to resign chairman of
the joint chiefs he's saying quote
i write with grave concerns regarding
recent reporting that general mark mille
chairman joint chiefs of staff worked to
actively undermine the sitting
commander-in-chief of the united states
armed forces
and contemplated a treasonous leak of
classified information to the chinese
communist party in advance of a
potential armed conflict with the
people's republic of china these actions
by general milley demonstrate a clear
lack of sound judgment and i urge you to
dismiss immediately
sure i just think that's too good uh
yeah i agree with rubio he he should be
fired immediately but but that's too
good there there needs to be a stiffer
consequence here
who's running the country who gets to
run the country you hear the left
prattle on and on and on and on about
our democracy and the threats to our
democracy
they are the
chief aggressors against our democracy
within the country
the democrats the the ruling class are
the chief
antagonists of our democracy
you see it all the time we talked about
this on the show last week
we need our democracy but if the people
of texas vote not to kill babies we've
got to undermine that we have our
democracy
unless the people vote for donald trump
as they did and then we have to
undermine that our democracy we need to
support our democracy and that's why we
need to
replace our commander-in-chief with some
careerist military woke idiot who's now
going to collude with our number one
enemy disgusting stuff it's not this is
not just right-wing
angst against millie
even
vindman you remember vin i'm sorry
lieutenant colonel vindman alexander
vinman he was this lib
disgruntled
really annoying
lieutenant colonel alexander vinman and
he came out and he was really active in
opposing trump he just said this is
outrageous and millie must resign
it says
if this report is true general milley
must resign he usurped civilian
authority broke chain of command and
violated the sacrosanct principle of
civilian control over the military it's
an extremely dangerous precedent
you can't simply walk away from that
hashtag do the right thing in the right
way i can't believe i'm saying this
general
general lieutenant colonel how could i
forget his title vindeman is correct now
the key here is
if this is true if this is we don't know
if this is true or not
especially because it comes from the
washington post especially because it
comes from this lib book by bob woodward
however as i have pointed out on the
show before
when reports come out in the
establishment media
against
establishment
figures against the left or against the
democrats they are more credible than
when reports come out in the
establishment media against the right
the reason for this is
that the
media
are on the same side as
the establishment they're the same thing
so when they're making some sort of
report about it
they have
one more credibility and and two
actually more access to the people who
are involved whereas because the media
and the right are in total opposition
because the media are the enemy the
they're the opponent
then the reports are are often less much
less credible than you the russia gate
the ukraine phone call the the moscow
urine tape you remember that remember
that nonsense for a while so that's just
not as as credible
is is this report correct i don't know
that's why we need to have an
investigation
we're seeing a real
upending of our constitution here
okay and it's it's by people who are not
elected the people who are claiming to
defend our democracy are the people who
are who are in practice undermining our
democracy notably dr fauci so dr fauci
is coming out now
and and discussing how much longer the
15 days to slow the spread is going to
go so he was asked
not that long ago just a few days ago on
the joy read show on msnbc
will there be a new
monster variant that forces us all to
lock down again that's why we need to
mandate the vaccines to stop is are we
headed for the very very worst of the
pandemic that's going to go on
interminably
fauci says no i've been liking it to
like the movie alien right where it's
one kind of alien that it morphs into
another kind and then another kind and
they just get more powerful as they
morph using the human body as a host
right so it's the same thing i worry
that we're on mu already i mean lambda i
was worried about now we're on mu we're
just going down the greek alphabet by
the time you know we get to omega i
worry it'll be unbeatable are you
worried that we're going to have a
nightmare this winter as these variants
continue to evolve
are we getting close to one that can
beat all of our vaccines well i'm not
saying we're close to that joy i i think
that would be a stretch to say that all
right i'm i'm always glad when dr fauci
weighs in as the voice of reason on to
the left and says no listen your
hysterical claims they're they're a
little too much even for me the problem
with fauci though is that he holds both
sides of every single opinion and he has
for decades so then he goes back on the
same channel msnbc he's being
interviewed by joe scarborough's
girlfriend i think now wife and who who
donald trump very famously had a big
problem with and uh this newscaster mika
brzezinski
asks him more or less the same question
and joe decides
or ifouchi decides instead not to tamp
down the hysteria but actually to turn
it up what is the potential
that this spirals beyond delta to
monster variant
well there's always a risk of as you get
more circulation of virus in the
community
that you'll get enough accumulation of
new mutations to get a variant
that is functionally different than the
ones we're seeing now you're vaccinating
now to prevent the next mutant coming
the next variant from coming and again
that's yet again another reason besides
protecting the health
of the people of getting vaccinated
protecting the community
you don't want to see more variants come
in because then it would in many
respects uh negate some of the very
positive protection that you get from
the vaccine so you do you notice how the
argument has evolved here from
well let's go all the way back to the
beginning 15 days to slow the spread
then it was flat in the curve then it
was fine to cure then we found a cure
then it was distribute the vaccines then
it was get vaccinated to protect
yourself then it was get vaccinated to
protect everybody else but i thought the
vaccine was supposed to provide the safe
effect of protection against severe
illness from the coronavirus to you to
the recipient so then that became a
little confused now it's get vaccinated
not so much to protect yourself or even
to protect other people but to protect
the future people who may or may not be
vaccinated against the lambda and the
sigma and the moo and the mao and the
phi beta kappa
it just goes on and on and on there's no
end to that
and so long as dr fauci gets to call the
shots and so long as dr fauci gets to go
on tv and run the country there never is
going to be any end to that
which is why he's going to keep turning
it up you're gonna if you go back
perhaps we should do a series on this if
you go back and look
at how dr fauci has evolved his
positions over the course of coronavirus
you'll notice that the the through line
here is no we would never do that crazy
radical thing that's not yet popular we
wouldn't do it well maybe we have to do
it we're doing it and if you don't do it
you hate science and you hate your
fellow americans and then he moves on no
we would never do this other radical
thing well maybe we would yes you
absolutely have to do it he goes on and
on and on and on and he rarely gets
called out for it he only gets called
out basically on on this show on the
right generally never from the
establishment and people move along with
it now
after we were told no vaccine mandates
by thouche
by joe biden we were told not only will
there not be vaccine mandates but
vaccine mandates would be an
encroachment on people's liberty then we
were told yes there will be vaccine
mandates i am mandating that you get the
vaccine now joe biden's commerce
secretary is going on after the
announcement for the vaccine mandates
and denying that there are mandates at
all i'm puzzled by these people who
continue to say they're forced
to get vaccinated here there's always
been a choice if you do not want to get
vaccinated you can work from home you
can homeschool your children you can
shop online so where is this coming from
people saying i'm now being forced to be
vaccinated we never forced vaccinations
on kids in school if you didn't want to
vaccinate your kids you could homeschool
them and people have done it for years
you're exactly right nobody's being
forced in fact if you don't get
vaccinated you just have to get tested
on a weekly basis but the reality is the
science is crystal clear on this
get it get vaccinated these vaccines are
incredibly effective
they're effective they are free they
work and we just it's unacceptable it is
unacceptable now that people aren't
getting vaccinated we need our kids in
schools we need the schools open we need
people to get back to work
so
notice what she says the science is
incredibly clear we need people back in
schools we need people to go to work we
need people to do this those aren't
scientific questions those are political
questions first of all but then look at
the weasel words she says look there is
no mandate you can always just get a
test
you can always get a test
tests are not free
tests are kind of expensive sometimes
even let's say you're just paying 25 30
bucks a test let's say you're a family
of four let's say you got to get a test
once a week twice a week that's going to
add up a lot you no one needs to get a
mandate or get a vaccine you just need
the vaccine or the constant tests if you
want to shop
or sell or work or travel or get on an
airplane or do anything that's the only
time you need to otherwise you're
otherwise
you're fine we're not mandating anything
at all
the pressure campaign
the pressure campaign is so
vicious because not only are they
mandating it but they're hiding the fact
that they're mandating it
if you want
to just see directly into
what you need how you can get it how you
can get it cheaply i would strongly
recommend you check out
rock auto when was the last time you
went to the brick and mortar car parts
store
do you remember you probably you might
not even remember this you show up
first you got to drive there it takes a
while then you got to walk in then you
got to wait in line you wait in line for
a little while you get up to the counter
you say okay i need i need this part for
my car the guy peppers you with the
thousand questions the bank the model
the color the this that you might not
might or might not know the answer to
those questions
then he looks in the back and they don't
have the part there's too many parts
there's too many cars these days there's
too many parts he goes online probably
at rockauto.com orders the part you've
got to wait a while and then you got to
pay twice as much or
or
just hear me out go to rockauto.com all
right family business they've got
reliably low prices for pros and
do-it-yourselfers it's not a bunch of
gimmicks it's not a bunch of log in on
tuesday morning and save 10 and then
wednesday it's 15 or whatever it's none
of that it's always reliably low they
got all the parts you need the catalog's
so easy to navigate even i can do it go
to rock odor dot com right now see all
the parts available for your car or
truck and then write noel skinner wle s
in there how did you hear about his box
so they know that we sent you and
speaking of vaccine mandates
you know where the daily wire is on this
okay we just said no
no no gina raymondo commerce secretary
there isn't you obviously you're
mandating there's no joe biden
you're mandating it and if we don't go
along with it for instance if we don't
go along with the employee vaccination
mandate
and testing we could face a fine of up
to fourteen thousand dollars for each
violation
which is why the daily wire is calling
on everyone who's listening to help us
fight this obscene tyrannical mandate go
to dailywire.com subscribe use code do
not comply at checkout for 25 off
we appreciate it
that you stand with us here at the daily
wire most importantly stand with the
rights of all americans we'll be right
back with a lot more
the people who say they defend our
democracy are the people most likely to
undermine our democracy the people who
pretend to be the radicals overthrowing
the system or the people who are most
likely to defend and entrench the system
in place it's ironic you can see it play
out right now
in a debate happening between nicki
minaj and joy reid
you know
a meeting of the great philosophers of
our era
nicki minaj is right here
joy reid is not right here but you're
gonna see joy read is very rarely right
but you're gonna see not just that one
side is right and one side is wrong it's
it's not a battle really between the
conservatives and the left or the left
and the right or anything like that
it's between
the outsiders and the ruling class
the the
entrenched power versus the people nicki
minaj tweets out they want you to get
vaccinated for the met gala if i get
vaccinated it won't be for the mech
gallup it'll be once i feel i've done
enough research i'm working on that now
in the meantime my loves be safe wear a
mask with two strings that grip your
hand and face grip your head and face
not that loose one so she's saying wear
the mask i'm going along with a lot of
this but i'm a little skeptical of this
hastily developed drug that we've been
hearing some weird stuff about
then she goes on to give a little
anecdote she goes
this is graphic so you know maybe close
your ears for 10 seconds if you need to
my cousin and trinidad won't get the
vaccine because his friend got it and
became impotent his testicles became
swollen his friend was weeks away from
getting married now the girl called off
the wedding so just pray on it and make
sure you're comfortable with your
decision not bullied well man if
anything is going to convince you not to
get the vaccine it will be that so she's
giving this anecdote but even beyond
this one anecdote
we've all heard these stories and the
cdc and the fda have actually
acknowledged a number of these stories
of perfectly young healthy people
getting myocarditis there's a 13 year
old who died a few days after he
received the second vaccine of heart
inflammation he was otherwise totally
healthy there have been people who died
of blood clots after getting the vaccine
that were related to the vaccine there
are people who have gotten nerve
disorders from the vaccines these things
actually have
happened
joy reid on msnbc
furiously responds people like nicki
minaj i have to say this
you have a platform sister that is 22
million followers okay i have two
million followers you have 22 million
followers on twitter for you to use your
platform to encourage our community to
not protect themselves and save their
lives my god sister you could do better
than that you got that platform
it's a blessing it's a blessing that you
got that that people listen to you and
they listen to you more they listen to
me
for you to use your platform to put
people in the position of dying
from a disease they don't have to die
from oh my god as a fan as a hip-hop fan
as somebody who was your fan i'm so sad
that you did that
so sad that you did that sister so joy
reid is engaging in what is called
concern trolling this this is not the
kind of trolling where you just attack
somebody outright this is the kind of
trolling where you pretend to be on the
person's side but you're actually
opposing everything that they're doing
and you're trying to say oh look i'm a
big fan of yours oh i just think i love
you oh i love your music and you're so
great and so i'm just i'm really sad
that you're that you're contradicting
the establishment narrative i'm just it
really concerns me that you are stepping
out of line from the ruling classes
narrative nicki minaj i'm just because
i'm a big fan of yours so
what does nicki minaj do did she say oh
well okay i'm sorry joy you're right i
shouldn't have stepped out of line maybe
next time maybe you should get the
vaccine no she doesn't do any of that
she says quote
this is what happens when you're so
thirsty to down another black woman by
the request of the white man that you
didn't bother to read all my tweets my
god sister do better imagine getting
your dumb derriere on tv a minute after
a tweet to spread a false narrative a
black about a black woman the two white
men sitting there not in their heads
because this uncle tom tamiana doing the
work child how sad
i love it i love it i know that she's
going after white people here and that's
i don't think that's good i think that's
bad for white people and i think it's
bad for swarthy people and i think it's
bad for the country in general but
to take it from nicki minaj's
perspective here
if you
the
the way that she is using the white man
here
is i think synonymous with the ruling
class okay i think the the wish you know
you ever hear about the man all the man
the man's getting me down or the white
man is you know
i think she's using this expression not
not to express her
hatred for white people in general maybe
she hates white people too i don't know
but i think she's using it to say
not you are a black shill for white
people but you are a shill for the
ruling power the ruling class now the
fact the fact is the the ruling class is
not presently defined by race or sex not
the white man it's the blob right it's
what we're talking about we call it the
liberal establishment call it whatever
you want
and
if you read nicki minaj's tweet as i
think you should in that way she's
completely right
she says this is what happens when
you're so thirsty to attack another
black woman she's saying look we're
supposed to be on the same side here
we're out of the power structure except
joy reads not out of the power structure
she's within the she works for corporate
media and her job is to push the
propaganda of the liberal establishment
you're doing this at the request of the
establishment
you're spreading a false narrative about
you coming after me who you have
something in common with but you're
doing it because you've sold out to the
establishment
this
i think is absolutely right this is what
aoc did too when aoc shows up to the met
gala to the fancy party with all her
extremely rich friends where no one's
wearing a mask and no one's following
their own rules other than the staff
other than the filthy dirty help so they
don't spread their germs to the good
rich people and she wears a dress and
says text the rich
she is
she is doing
what i accuse the squishy conservatives
of doing you know i call those squishy
conservatives the court jesters in the
kingdom of liberalism aoc is the same
thing she's the same thing for the left
she is performing this role as a radical
leftist revolutionary she is doing
nothing but propping up the
capitalistic liberal establishment
plutocracy that's that's her job she is
a she is a court jester for the radical
left and she puts on a show and she's
supposed to get all the leftists really
riled up but her her job really is to
preserve the establishment that's why
she's partying with people at the med
gala
when we talk about people on the right
who are the sort of conservatives who go
on the liberal channels and they say
well i'm a conservative but i would
never support donald trump i'm a
conservative but i would never support
pro-life laws i'm a conservative but i
would never support borders and
immigration controls i'm a conservative
but i would never support you know
anything that's actually conservative
they are court jesters on the right and
aoc and joy reid are court jesters on
the left
their job is to put up just enough of a
fight to give the radical leftists the
feeling that they can really
completely overthrow the broad liberal
establishment
which is not opposed to the big
corporations but is actually part of the
big corporations in fact though when
those when those corporate globalist
establishmentarian masters come down and
say hey
hey joy reid
hey aoc
hey
people that we permit to have some power
in this system get in line
and get the rest of your people in line
too
what do they do
they do it hey joy reid hey aoc
jump
how high how high corporate overlords
and nicki minaj isn't going to do that
i have a great even though nicki minaj
is just coming out very strongly against
white men in this in this tweet which is
not great
i i do
at least appreciate the place that she's
doing it from it's a recognition of the
real political power and the real role
of these make-believe radicals on msnbc
or in the halls of congress like aoc
where is the radicalism megan repino
she's that
soccer player i guess she's the soccer
player who hates america and she's very
performatively lesbian she went to the
met gala
and she wore or she carried with herself
a clutch purse that says in gay we trust
right not in god we trust in gay we
trust because her god
is
sexual desire and radicalism and
subversion and the overthrow of
traditional order i suppose right
the whole point of it is the subversion
of an
ordinary american slogan
and this is supposed to be revolutionary
except except
she's doing it at the met gala
except she's doing it with the richest
most entrenched most establishmentarian
people
in the entire country
she thinks she's upending the tr the
american religion is christianity and
she's going to upend it and make it this
religion about sexual desire no no
her version the lgbt the rainbow flag
the pride the progress that is
the established church that is the
official religion
if i showed up to the met gala in a
dress
i that that would be fine they would be
that would be totally normal but if i
showed up in a dress
or with a clutch purse that said stop
killing babies
or
i don't know even on you could go even
further on that line down syndrome lives
stop killing people with down syndrome
which which the left openly advocates
doing so in the womb
i would be escorted out by security i
would never get in the door because that
would be a genuinely radical slogan it
would be a genuinely revolutionary
slogan
if if i
wore a
costume into the met gala that said
we need election integrity to make sure
that every vote counts
defend election integrity laws i would
be escorted out
because the ruling class doesn't want
any of that stuff
the ruling class wants the bread and the
circuses of the megan repino and the aoc
and the joy read
and they want
they want to keep the show going while
they rule the country
that that is that is the established
church that we're living in right now
because all human conflict ultimately is
theological speaking of radical churches
the evangelical lutheran church
the elca
has just installed its first transgender
bishop
i'm going to need to use a lot of quotes
here
the evangelical lutheran church in
america has just installed its first
transgender
bishop
we covered this back when it was
starting to bubble up in the
news cycle a while ago
at grace cathedral in san francisco
with 65 bishops and 150 pastors in
attendance bishop megan rohrer will lead
the sacramento-based sierra pacific
synod with 200 caligations
congregations the 41 year old
woman
now uses the pronouns he
and they and hold on it gets weirder is
married to a wife
named laurel and the couple
has two children
has
to how i don't i don't know none of this
makes any sense none of this is real
what you are witnessing here is not just
the destruction of
marriage and sex and the church you're
seeing the destruction of the english
language because this is a bunch of
gobbledygook that doesn't mean anything
and we're not because of our
i suppose in part because we have a
respect for pluralistic society but then
we've taken that to a radical radical
extreme of skepticism we're not allowed
to point out that this is not really a
church this woman is not really a bishop
and
this woman is not really a man we're not
allowed to appoint any and
this this woman is not really the
husband to her wife with none
none of that is true
this is
a lesbian who is playing make-believe at
religion
to promote the her true religion which
is the religion of progressivism
this is the destruction of the
institution we're seeing the destruction
of of church institutions the
destruction of public health
institutions we're seeing the
destruction of military institutions
thank you general mattis we're seeing
the the collapse
of basically all of the institutions of
public life we no longer even have faith
in our elections whether the elections
in california whether the election is
nationwide
whether it's the democrat who wins
whether it's the republican who wins
we no longer have faith in those
institutions that's not the fault of the
people it's the fault of the people who
ran the institutions into the ground
speaking of institutions mattering
there's a woman who's up for
a judge
judgeship on the ninth circuit
this is a biden nominee and senator cruz
has some questions for her
miss sung
do you believe justice kavanaugh is
intellectually and morally bankrupt
senator
i would want every supreme court justice
to know including justice kavanaugh that
i respect completely their authority as
a supreme court justice i never would
follow their precedence without
reservation you're an experienced lawyer
you know when someone's not answering a
question my question was simple and
straightforward
do you believe justice kavanaugh is
quote
intellectually and morally bankrupt
thank you for the question senator as i
stated earlier i recognized that that
statement was overheated rhetoric and
that's all that it was
so
correct me if i'm wrong i'm not as
trained a lawyer as senator cruz here or
as this nominee is but it sounds like
she didn't answer the question again so
she comes out and she says
this was
some time ago she says
brett kavanaugh is intellectually
morally bankrupt this wasn't it wasn't
that wasn't 10 years ago this was you
know within the last few years and cruz
says okay so do you believe that
and if you do not believe that were you
lying then or are you lying now where is
your credibility because you told us you
made a very forceful statement about it
now a member of the supreme court not
that not all that long ago so what is it
are you a liar do you have any integrity
joe biden's judicial nominee 9th circuit
court
cannot answer
simple questions
from senator cruz
i'm going to try one more time because
you signed your name to it and it wasn't
year decades ago it was it was very
recently
you sign your name to this statement i'm
asking simply today
do you believe that justice kavanaugh is
quote
intellectually and morally bankrupt you
signed your name to that proposition do
you still believe it
thank you for the question senator as i
stated
that was rhetorical advocacy only that i
signed strictly in my personal capacity
as a private citizen addressing my alma
mater
that was
rhetorical
advocacy that that was overheated and
does not represent her view so hold on
let me try to make sense of that
rhetorical advocacy
is when you use words
to make a point
and in this case she's admitting she
used words to make a point but she
didn't believe in those oh she lied oh
you lied that was a lie okay
she's saying
yes when i
signed my name to that statement not
that long ago
i
was a liar
that's what i said about brett kavanaugh
then but now i don't believe it so the
question of course is if you were
willing to lie very publicly not that
long ago
what's to say you're not lying right now
to me
and the answer is nothing because this
woman has no integrity and it doesn't
matter she'll probably get through
because our institutions have very
little integrity these days and and then
the institutionalists and the
establishmentarians want to blame all of
us and call us
insurrectionists and call us
terrorists and threats to to the united
states in our democracy
because we have questions about the way
that these people
have lied to us and continue to lie to
us day by day by day and even lied to us
about lying to us
speaking of these mealy-mouthed words
poor besieged secretary of state anthony
blinken
was asked another simple question
question is quote is it true that that
vladimir putin threatened the united
states
this is there were some reports about
this he goes is that true did that
really happen did he threaten joe biden
blinken gives a similar sort of answer
to that judge is it true that president
putin
threatened the president united states
saying he could not build intelligence
capabilities in the region
um
this is a this is an important question
and one that in its detail and substance
i think we need to take up
in another setting for reasons i know
that you you very much appreciate
this is a very important question and i
think we certainly need to take it up
and uh yes we should do it uh when it's
off the record so that i don't need to
actually give an answer on this
such
weakness
did vladimir putin threaten the united
states that if we try to interfere
anymore in afghanistan and the region
that they're they're going to hit us
they're going to attack us they're going
to retaliate did that happen why aren't
we hearing about this why are we doing
something about this
why isn't general milly calling china
and
selling american intelligence
why
why why why
because
it would seem to me that the way that we
are told our government works
in schoolhouse rock i'm a bill and up on
capitol hill is not the way our
government actually works and if the
past few years have done anything it's
it's
woken us up to that fact
it's made us question well hold on wait
the top general the top military
commander in america is
reportedly offering to give
extraordinarily classified information
to the chinese government by undermining
his own president and wait hold what
what
wait are people don't have any faith in
our elections anymore what ah yikes oh
that's not good
that's not good and then the cherry on
top of this
difficult day sunday
the funniest man in the world just died
norm mcdonald i know there are a lot of
norm mcdonald fans out there i was gonna
play a clip from norm today and i
couldn't pick just one i couldn't his
work is so good i've i've read his book
based on a true story three times we've
all watched his videos you know many
many many times you could go down a
youtube rabbit hole and be there for
days
so i did just want to give a little
personal insight
i wish that i could say that norm
mcdonald and i were best friends that
would be incredible but i you know i
unfortunately i can't say that
um
however we we did have a very lengthy
correspondence
a couple of years ago
i noticed when norm mcdonald got onto
twitter he
followed me i was one of the first
people he followed on twitter and i was
i was really shocked by this and i
thought like i you know i never messaged
him i was so in awe of the guy i didn't
want to
abuse the fact that he was he was
following me and but then one one time
he tweeted something about some pain
that he was in
and so i did reach out i didn't know if
he was depressed or suicidal even now in
retrospect we see he was going through
cancer treatments he suffered silently
privately from cancer he fought cancer
for nine years didn't tell anyone
apparently not even much of his family
if any of his family
and
so i reached out to and i said hey you
know if you want to talk about anything
just let me know and this led to
a weeks and weeks-long correspondence
where we would write each other
basically these essays every night these
very long letters every night and it was
mostly on the topic of religion
which you
and i you could never tell if he was
making a joke or something he would
sometimes talk about religion publicly
but he would it would usually be in the
form of a joke he'd say i'm a christian
you know and someone
the other comedian would say you're a
christian he's like yeah you know i
protest military funerals you know yeah
like the westboro church or something
and say okay i don't know if he really
is
all i will say i don't want to reveal
too much about our private
correspondence certainly not not now
but
the thing you noticed about norm
was that he was one of the wisest people
most intelligent people around he would
he would say these things like you know
michael man you're really educated man
you're really intelligent me i'm just an
old chunk of coal you know i'm not
educated at all and he would use some
word that i'd never heard before and you
could tell he had this deep deep
knowledge of literature and history and
philosophy and all of these things and
we we got into this very serious
conversation about religion and the one
comfort that i and the reason i even
mentioned this today is comfort for all
the many many fans he had out there
i am quite certain that he had obviously
profound humility
and a deep
and abiding faith i am quite certain of
that and obviously a great deal of
fortitude which is another virtue which
is really missing in our culture today
when was the last time someone suffered
privately and died privately and didn't
make a big spectacle of himself and
didn't become a victim
and just fought his struggles and
carried his cross silently
it's a
horrible loss to the world that he has
gone uh but he remains a great
inspiration to a lot of people and he
left behind a great body of work and i
strongly recommend you all check out his
book based on a true story
cheers to norm mcdonald
one of the greats i'm michael knowless
the michael null show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
borin our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nika geneva michael
knowles show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matte
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show